und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend angela merkel betont ja
selten dass sie ostdeutsche ist
vielleicht zu selten heute taxis und sie
sprach auch nicht nur darüber was alles
schon erreicht worden ist sind den
letzten 29 jahren sondern sagte auch die
staatliche einheit sei voll sei zwar
vollendet die einheit der deutschen aber
nicht
und merkel wurde grundsätzlich mit der
warnung nicht immer zuerst den staat
oder sogenannte eliten für jede
widrigkeit des lebens verantwortlich zu
machen
insofern nutzte sie die offiziellen
feierlichkeiten zum tag der deutschen
einheit für grundsätzliche politische
botschaften was sie auch eher selten
gefeiert wurde hoch im norden die
bundesländer wechseln sicher bei der
jährlichen einheitsfeier ab diesmal war
viel dran
von dort berichtet hermann barth
tausende sind zum tag der deutschen
einheit nach kiel gekommen
die innenstadt voll wie selten es sind
mehr menschen unterwegs seid zur kieler
woche scherzen einige familie freier aus
lübeck ist gerade mit dem zug angekommen
sie aus dem westen eher aus dem osten
ohne die wände während sie wohl kein
paar
ich komme aus dem tiefsten ruhrgebiet
und er aus dem erzgebirge und
dementsprechend ohne den fall der mauer
gäbe es diese drei kinder nicht ich
finde es schön dass wir uns wie alle
hier treffen und mal unsere
vielfältigkeit feiern dadurch das ist
echt schön
der tag der deutschen einheit beginnt in
kiel mit viel protokoll eintrag ins
goldene buch der stadt danach ein
ökumenischer gottesdienst in der
nikolaikirche mit den
spitzenrepräsentanten der republik
es bleibt nur wenig zeit für gespräche
mit bürgern und für autogramme beim
festakt am mittag würde ich die
kanzlerin die leistungen der
ostdeutschen bei der überwindung der
sed-diktatur die revolution konnte
erfolgreich sein weil mutige bürgerinnen
und bürger auch die spd strukturen vor
ort entmachteten bürgerinnen und bürger
die die lokalen repräsentanten der ddr
in großen und kleinen städten
in einem dialog zwang dem diese nichts
entgegensetzen konnten
angela merkel erinnert an die opfer der
sed diktatur
diese sollten nicht vergessen werden die
staatliche einheit sei zwar vollendet
die der menschen aber noch lange nicht
viele ostdeutsche fühlten sich nach wie
vor als bürger zweiter klasse
die einheit der deutschen ihr einig sein
das war am dritten oktober 1990 noch
nicht vollendet und das ist es bis heute
nicht
die deutsche einheit ist also kein
zustand einmal vollendet und
abgeschlossen sondern ein fortwährender
prozess ständiger auftrag ein prozess
der alle deutschen betrifft egal in
welchem bundesland sie blieben
ministerpräsident daniel günther waren
in seiner rede davor das wort wende in
der politischen auseinandersetzung zu
missbrauchen und es ist eine verhöhnung
der leistung dieser menschen wenn partei
diesen mut heute für ihre
parteipolitischen zwecke missbrauchen
indem sie von der wende 2.0 reden
diese wende als historische
lebensleistung der ostdeutschen bleibt
singulär und untrennbar mit dem ende der
ddr verbunden meine damen und herren
direkt am wasser präsentieren sich die
bundesländer werben für ihre region gut
verbindet das motto des einheits festes
für viele ist es ein ganz besonderer tag
ich glaube der mensch braucht braucht
anlässe und wir bestimmte dinge
nachzudenken das sind geburtstage aber
das kann eben zum beispiel auch dieser
tag sein und hätten wir die nicht
weiß ich nicht ab man darüber nachdenken
würde zur stunde gibt es noch eine show
mit musik licht und videos auf drei
schwimmenden bühne auf der förde um 23
uhr ende des bürgerfest in kiel
der einigungsprozess geht weiter
[Musik]
bundesinnenminister seehofer ist zu
besuch in der türkei
wie lange sich ankara noch an das
flüchtlings abkommen mit der eu hält ist
eine frage die nicht nur die
bundesregierung und treibt die zahl der
flüchtlinge die sich von der türkei aus
richtung europa aufmachen ist zuletzt ja
deutlich gestiegen
präsident erdogan hat mehr unterstützung
gefordert und gedroht er werde
andernfalls die tore aufmachen erdogan
steht selbst dabei unter druck
seit beginn des kriegs im benachbarten
syrien sind mehr als dreieinhalb
millionen flüchtlinge in die türkei
gekommen
zu viele finden inzwischen viele türken
thomas gilt berichtet das
flüchtlingscamp nur wenige kilometer von
der türkischen grenze
zehntausende syrer suchen ihr schutz vor
der offensive des assad regimes
wo soll ich hin halt mein dorf ist von
der armee besetzt ich kann nicht zurück
sollte er liebt die letzte provinz der
rebellen fallen dann rechnet ankara mit
noch mehr flüchtlinge schon jetzt hätte
die türkei die hauptlast zu tragen zu
erdogan in dieser woche wir haben nicht
vor millionen von flüchtlingen auf
unserem boden für immer zu beherbergen
der kurzfristig anberaumten besuch des
deutschen innenministers mit dem
migrationskommission angra zeigt wie
besorgt die europäischen partner sind
sie wollen wissen warum wieder mehr
flüchtlinge über das mittelmeer kommen
doch zunächst einmal gibt es viel lob an
den gastgeber ohne solidarität wäre das
migrationsproblem in unserer region so
nicht bewältigt wurden ein ganz
herzliches dankeschön
das ist eine leistung die auch in die
welt historie eingeht
doch der flüchtlings pakt mit der türkei
hat schwächen nur knapp 2000 illegale
flüchtlinge hat die türkei sei 2016
zurückgenommen die gäste aus berlin
brüssel und paris wollen dass es
deutlich mehr werden
der türkische innenminister betont dass
sein land den vertrag mit der eu erfüllt
die migration ist das größte problem im
21ten jahren land wir stehen vor vielen
problem aber trotz der fünf millionen
migranten in unserem land davon 3,6
millionen syrer kann ich sagen wir
halten uns an die abmachungen ankara
sieht sich in der flüchtlingsfrage nicht
genug gewertschätzt drängt auf eine
schnellere auszahlung der hilfen und
macht werbung für erdogans neuestes
flüchtlings projekt den sicherheits
streichen
präsident erdogan hat die
sicherheitszone schon bei der
un-vollversammlung vorgestellt darüber
werden wir jetzt gemeinsam die
sogenannte sicherheitszone soll im
nordosten syriens entstehen direkt
hinter der türkischen grenze erdogan
will dort mit internationaler hilfe
mindestens zwei millionen syrer aus der
türkei ansiedeln die türkische regierung
hofft dass sie dabei von ihren
europäischen partnern großzügig
unterstützt werden
mit der flüchtlingskinder steht es jetzt
auch in den nachrichten erst noch weiter
heisst das eu-parlament hat sich heute
in einem ausschuss mit den such und
rettungsaktionen im mittelmeer
beschäftigt und hatte dazu auch die
deutsche kapitänin carola rakete zu gast
sie schilderte ihre erfahrungen und
forderte eine eu-weite regelung für die
seenotrettung von migranten im
mittelmeer
die eu solle ihre humanitären auftrag
ernst nehmen und verantwortung nicht an
länder wie libyen abgeben
[Applaus]
nachdem der britische premierminister
boris johnson gestern in brüssel seinen
vorschlag für eine änderung des brh exit
abkommens vorgelegt hat kommt heute von
der eu-kommission eine zurückhaltende
reaktion
es gebe in dem vorschlag problematische
punkte
großbritannien müsse hier nacharbeiten
als johnson sagte dagegen im parlament
in london
er habe große flexibilität gezeigt wenn
die europäischen nachbarn mit eben
solchen einigungswillen zeiten leider am
31 oktober nur ein brett ohne abkommen
knapp fünf wochen nach der landtagswahl
steuer sachsen auf eine koalition aus
cdu grünen und spd zu die
sondierungsgespräche wurden heute
abgeschlossen jetzt wollen die
verhandlungsführer der parteien in den
jeweiligen gremien
koalitionsverhandlungen für
koalitionsverhandlungen werben
zum dritten oktober gehört seit über 20
jahren auch der tag der offenen moschee
heute haben wieder rund 1000 muslimische
gebetshäuser in deutschland ihre türen
für besucher geöffnet darunter die ditib
zentralmoschee in köln ehrenfeld
ziel der veranstaltung ist es über den
islam zu informieren und mit
nichtmuslimen ins gespräch zu kommen
im mittelpunkt stand in diesem jahr das
thema heimat in paris hat ein
mitarbeiter der polizeipräfektur heute
vier kollegen getötet
der täter wurde von einem polizisten
erschossen
der messerangriff passierte im
polizeihauptquartier in der nähe der
kathedrale notre dame
der 45-jährige täter arbeitete dort als
verwaltungsangestellter inzwischen haben
ermittler seinen wohnsitz durchsucht
über sein motiv ist noch nichts bekannt
wer sich gegen hass im netz wären will
hat es ja eh schon schwer in
juristischen hürden sind hoch hat man
aber erfolgreich eine gerichtliche
anordnung erreicht beginnt das nächste
problem
wie bekommt man die post oder tweets
auch tatsächlich aus dem netz entfernt
facebook macht es sich da bekanntlich
gerne leicht und versteckt sich dahinter
hat nur eine plattform zu sein und keine
redaktion die verantwortung übernimmt
für die inhalte die sie veröffentlicht
mit dieser argumentation kommt der
konzern aber schon länger nicht mehr
davon
und jetzt hat der europäische
gerichtshof die verpflichtung der
plattformen rechtswidrige inhalte zu
löschen sogar noch ausgeweitet
den anstoß dafür gab eine ehemalige
österreichische politikerin die gegen
facebook geklagt hatte
felix zimmermann berichtet als herkules
in der griechischen mythologie gegen die
hydra kämpfen musste stand der vor allem
durch aus schwerwiegenden problem auch
wenn es ihm gelang einen der vielen
köpfe des schlangenartigen wesens
abzuschlagen wuchsen dort sofort zwei
neue nach ganz ähnlich verläuft
heutzutage der kampf gegen hass im netz
selbst wer es mit großem aufwand schafft
bei facebook twitter und co die löschung
einer beleidigung zu erreichen muss
frustrierend feststellen dass immer
neuer nachfolgen
so erging es etwa der ehemaligen grünen
vorsitzenden aus österreich die
vergleiche schneck als sie sich für die
versorgung von flüchtlingen aussprach
wurde sie auf facebook als korruptes
trampel beschimpft dass eine faschisten
partei angehöre
das war einfach nicht mehr erträglich
für sich das jeden tag anzuschauen und
wir haben uns dann eigentlich bewusst
entschieden hier auch eine rote linie zu
ziehen
sie klagte in österreich zusammen mit
ihrer anwältin gegen facebook und
gewandt doch facebook löscht nur den
gerichtlich verbotenen beitrag und das
auch nur in österreich
außerdem weigert sich facebook
alternativ formulierungen zum
gerichtlich verbotenen gruppen trampel
zu suchen und zu entfernen
wie etwa coop das trampeltier heute
entschied nun der europäische
gerichtshof facebook muss bei einer
beschwerde nicht nur wort identische
sondern auch sinn gleiche beiträge
anderer user suchen und löschen
doch wie soll facebook sinn gleiche
beiträge im großen internet finden
der gerichtssprecher des ogh erklärt
dass das muss dem hosting anbieter
möglich bleiben sie anhand
automatisierter techniken ausfindig zu
machen
im klartext der ogh fordert von facebook
die einrichtung von technischen
wortfilter also upload filtern die
lösungen automatisieren
viele stimmen befürchten hier ein
eingriff in die meinungsfreiheit
außerdem sagt der ogh nationale gerichte
dürfen facebook sogar verpflichten
inhalte weltweit zu löschen
das ist problematisch weil das
verständnis der meinungsfreiheit
weltweit unterschiedlich ist
entsprechend scharf kritisiert facebook
das in einer stellungnahme das urteil
untergräbt den langjährigen grundsatz
dass ein land nicht das recht hat einem
anderen land seien die gesetze
aufzuerlegen
der ogh hat mit seiner heutigen
entscheidung einen wendepunkt im kampf
gegen hass im netz eingeleitet und die
persönlichkeitsrechte der eu bürger
gestärkt
die entscheidung rückt aber auch
herausforderung für den weltweiten
schutz der meinungsfreiheit und jetzt
nochmal zurück zum besonderen datum
dritter oktober wenn der berliner
fernsehturm wird 50 1969 eröffnet damals
noch eine reine ddr attraktion ist er
jetzt 50 jahre später ein
touristenmagnet mitten in der hauptstadt
und gilt als ein symbol des
wiedervereinigten berlin soll ergebnisse
vom zweiten spieltag der
fußball-europa-league santi entgegen den
vfl wolfsburg eins zu eins und auch die
partie istanbul war schalke hier gegen
borussia mönchengladbach findet eins zu
eins
jetzt noch die wetteraussichten morgen
wird es nass von westen setzen sich
regenwolken durch die bis zum abend den
osten erreichen höchstwerte zwischen 9
und 14 grad
und auch in den nächsten tagen gibt es
wenig änderungen es bleibt wechselhaft
bei maximal 7 bis 14 grad
in ihrer rede zur einheitsfeier ließ
angela merkel auch anklingen dass es
westdeutschen oft an verständnis dafür
fehle was es bedeutet wenn sich das
ganze system in dem man gelebter
praktisch über nacht auflöst
umso mehr seit er jetzt nachfolgende
fernsehfilm empfohlen im zeiten des
abnehmenden lichts die verfilmung des
bestsellers von eugen ruge mit bruno
ganz in der rolle des patriarchen einer
zerbrechenden familie in der ddr und um
0.55 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express und uns morgen
ich habe wieder sehen
[Musik]